so quello che ho detto ok ma coppetta
come baby piccola medio grande medio
piccola grandissima ex super gigante
quanti gusti no cara se vuoi tre gusti
devi prenderla gigante extra gigabyte
che questi ci sono
livelli ma ci sta e leggere signora come
glielo spiego il pistacchio normale è
normale di pisa accusate sarà the beast
che salatissimo un po più salato solo
cioccolato e video che tristezza cosa
può abbinare al pistacchio ha visto che
ci può abbinare tutto tu puoi abbinare
al limone il caffè cioccolato la
maionese la salsa di soia basa abili che
tutto sia allora il gusto del mese a e
ricotta aceto balsamico e cipolla di
tropea caramel loda poi il giro da ohio
per caso
no perché tutta la questione di peso
specifico se ti ho messo fuori di latte
per ultimo c'è un motivo perché capito
si scioglie prima una vaschetta quanta
persona due persone questo è un chilo e
mezzo troppo
facciamo allora non lo so da un
cucchiaino ti fai un assaggio che ne va
a casa ma pensate